we're on problem number six and actually
figured out how to cut and paste from
the PDF file to my little writing board
so we actually have access to the
problem so it says what system of
inequalities best represents the graph
shown below so we want to figure out
what inequalities represents this shaded
area so a good place to start is just to
figure out what these dotted line graphs
what the equations of them look like so
this one let's do the hard one first
right this is at an angle so whenever I
look at a line I like to think of you
know what's its slope and what's its
y-intercept right and you could just
write it in the form y is equal to MX
plus B where B is the y-intercept and m
is the slope right so let's try to
figure out the equation of this line up
here this dotted line so what's its
slope so when I move over 1 and X when I
move over to the right when x increases
by 1 or let's say when x increases by 2
how much does y increase well Y
increases by 2 as well or whatever we
increase X by if x increases by 1 then y
increases by 1 so the slope is 1 right
slope is slope is just change in Y over
change in X right so the slope of this
first line is 1 so m is equal to 1 for
at least this first line up here and
what's its y intercept the y intercept
is just weird what is the graph equal
when x is equal to 0 or where does it
intersect the y-axis well it intersects
the y-axis right here right here at y is
equal to 1 so b is equal to 1 so the
graph of this the equation of this
dotted line up here is y is equal to MX
the slope times X we figured out the
slope was one so that's X plus the
y-intercept which we also figured out
where we want was one so that's the
graph of that line right but notice the
shaded region is below that line the
shape and it also does not include the
line right B that's why they drew it a
dotted line if it was a solid line that
means that we're including the line
itself but the shaded region does not
include the line but it's below it think
of it this way for any given X
if let's pick this X let me do in a
different color let me do it in blue if
i were to put pic x is equal to 1 right
this is the point y is equal to x plus 1
that's the equation now my question to
you is is why above y is equal to x plus
1 is a shaded region y is greater than X
plus 1 which would be that region or
would it be y is less than X plus 1
which is this region right well clearly
it's y is less than X plus 1 you pick
any X X is equal to 3 this is what y
would be equal to y would be equal to 3
plus 1 if you pick this choice but the
gray is all the Y's that satisfy the
gray are always less than this point so
at least the gray or relative to this
equation we can write the inequality y
is less than X plus 1 and we know it's
not less than or equal to it would be
less than or equal to if they had filled
in this line if this was part of the
area but it's not they drew a dotted
line so that's why we know it's less
than right if the gray area was up here
would be greater than you just pick and
actually say oh this is y is less than
the line not the wise greater but we're
not done right because this would be the
solution set this would be the solution
set if if all of this area was great but
it's only gray up to a certain point
it's only gray up to this line down here
this lines easier this line has no slope
right no matter what might change in X
might change in Y is 0 so what's the
equation of this the equation of this
line is just you know slope is 0 so y is
equal to 0 X plus the y-intercept well
the y-intercept is minus 2 so the
equation of this line is y is equal to
minus to let me do it in the purple let
me write it I'll just write it here
that's that equation is y is equal to
minus 2 which makes sense for all X Y is
equal to minus 2 now my question to you
is this gray area for any given X does
the greater set or is it the Y is
greater than the line or the Y is less
than the line well clearly let's let you
know let's pick this X right when x is
equal to 3 y is equal to negative 2
that's this line now is the gray area
the wise for that X above the line or
below
let's above the line right so if we look
at it from the point of view of this
this boundary we say that Y has to be
greater than minus 2 that's the shaded
area right y is equal to negative 2 is
this dotted lines equation the shaded
area at least relative to this line is y
is greater than negative 2 so if I
wanted to put a constraint on if i want
to say what the shaded area if I just
had this by itself I would shade up
everything above y is equal to negative
2 right but I want just the combination
of both of these so essentially we have
to say that why let me do it in a nice
vibrant color since the shaded area is
below this line we know that Y is less
than X plus 1 and since the shaded area
is above this line we know that Y y is
greater than negative 2 where can I
write that I'll write it right here y is
greater than negative 2 so which of the
choices satisfy that let's see whoops I
went to the next problem so we know that
Y is greater than negative 2 so these
can't let me cross those out that and
that can't be the answer and then we
also know that y is less than X plus 1
and so we know that this is the answer
and frankly you didn't even have to if
you just looked at the choices you
really didn't have to figure out the
slope and y-intercept they're
essentially giving you the equations of
the two lines right your sake 0 1 is X
plus 1 and 1 is negative 2 and I just
have to figure out whether y is greater
than or less than each of those lines
and you can say ok relative to the y
equals negative 2 we're definitely
greater than negative 2 so I'm one of
these two choices and relative to Y is
equal to X plus 1 we're definitely less
than that line so we have to be choice B
next problem which point lies in the
solution set for the system so you
essentially just have to say which
coordinates satisfy both of these
equations and frankly you could graph
them and you could draw the area like we
did in the last one or you could just
try out the numbers right let's just try
out the numbers that never hurts let's
see so minus 41 let's see if it
satisfies it so remember the first
coordinate is X the second one is why so
too why would be 2 times minus 1
minus X so minus minus 4 now is that
greater than or equal to minus 6 well
this is minus 2 plus 4 and this is what
minus 2 plus 4 is equal to 2 which is
definitely greater than or equal to
minus 6 so it satisfies the first
equation let's see if it satisfies the
second equation I'll do it another color
i'll do it up in life and the black area
up here so 2 times y so it's 2 times
minus 1 right y is minus 1 minus three x
minus four minus three x minus 4 and
they want to know is that less than
minus six so you get minus 2 3 times 4
is 12 so it's plus plus 12 plus 12 right
negative times a negative is a positive
so that equals plus 10 which is not less
than negative 6 so the first one does
not work that is not the answer let's
try the second one 3 comma 1 so y is 1
so it becomes 2 times 1 which is just
2-3 is that greater than or equal to
negative 6 so you get negative 1 is
definitely greater than negative 6 so
this satisfies the first equation does
it satisfy the second one two times y to
x 1 to x 1 is 2 minus 3 times 3 minus 3
times 3 is that less than minus 60 you
get 2 minus nine is that less than minus
6 you get minus 7 it is less than minus
60 that is true so choice B works don't
have to go any further that point lies
in the solution set which just means it
satisfies both of these inequalities
next problem scroll down a little bit
let's see which system of linear
equality is represented by this graph so
now we could use some of the skills we
use the last time see I don't have much
space to draw all of them so let's just
try to figure out the let's see em do
they give us now they don't even give us
the equations because all the equations
doing so we have to figure out the
equations of these
two graphs so let's do this this top one
first right so let's figure out its
slope when you increase and you can just
eyeball this one when you increase X by
let's increase X by three Y increases by
the same amount right so change in Y
over change in X would be three over
three whatever you change X by Y
increases the same amount so the slope
of this first one at least let me do it
in a color you can see over black the
slope is equal to one and what's its
y-intercept well you just say where did
it intersect the y-axis right there so
the y-intercept is equal to minus two so
this first equation this first equation
right here is y is equal to X minus 2
fair enough and this gray area is it
above or below it it's below it you pick
any X for any X this is y is equal to X
minus 2 the gray area is for the all the
Y's that are less than it right and
notice now the line is shaded in so the
line is part of the solution set right
so at least relative to this we know
that the gray area is all-wise that
satisfy y is less than or equal to X
minus 2 less than because it's below it
and it's equal to because it they
actually drew in the line but now we
have to figure out the lower bound
what's the equation of this line so
let's think about it a little bit this
one's a little more interesting if i
were to if I increase X by 1 if I
increase X by 1 so if I'm going from
this point if I increase X by 1 what
happens to y y goes down by two right
1-2 if I increase X by 2 y goes down by
four right minus 4 so at least in this
case the slope change in Y is minus 4
whenever change in X is positive 2 or it
could have been you know change in Y is
minus 2 whenever change in x is plus 1
right so it equals minus 2 and that
makes sense for everyone you go over the
slope goes down to and what's its
y-intercept let's see y intercept is
just right there y is equal to 3 so b is
equal to 3 so
this second graph is y is equal to minus
2x plus 3 and once again the shaded area
increase it includes this but we have to
be greater than or equal to this graph
right we have to be greater than because
if you pick any X the Y's that satisfy
the shaded area are equal to the graph
or greater than for any X so there we
have our we have our inequality so this
one this area you could kind of say is
why has to be greater than or equal to
minus 2x plus 3 that's from this
boundary and we also know that Y has to
be less than or equal to X minus 2 now
hopefully that's one of the choices if
we haven't made a careless mistake let
me see all right y is greater than or
equal to okay there we see so this is
not the answer neither of these are the
answers that's not the answer let me
cross that out y is greater than equal
to we have minus 2x plus 3 all right let
me make sure I got that right minus 2x
plus yeah let me see right so there's
tricky so this is we the slope on that
second line is minus 2x plus 3 they got
the second part right maybe I made a
careless mistake but I don't think this
is right either let's see if we can
rearrange so these other two they put
the XS and the Y's on the same side so
let's do that if we that top equation we
can rewrite it at 2x to both sides you
get 2x plus y is greater than or equal
to 3 and the second equation if we were
to let's see if we were to subtract X
from both sides you get y minus x is
less than or equal to minus 2 and now
this is interesting so there's no minus
2 on the right hand side here but what
can we do if we multiply both sides of
this equation by minus two what happens
you get ma sorry multiply both sides
equation x minus 1 you get minus y plus
X and when you multiply an inequality by
a negative number multiply or divide you
switch to the inequalities so that's
great
than or equal to and we multiplying by
negative 12 so it becomes X minus y is
greater than or equal to 2 so our two
equations turn into 2x plus y is greater
than or equal to 3 which is this one and
we get X minus y is greater than or
equal to 2 which is that one and we're
done is choice D see you in the next
video